hola qué tal muy buenos días vos
mencionabas algunos de los puntos
concretos pero si uno tiene que
encontrar elementos que ponen un
conjunto dentro de un conjunto todos
estos mensajes diversos de los
manifestantes yo creo que están por un
lado una oposición fuerte al gobierno de
alberto fernández como mencionados pero
también un enojo muy grande y
persistente contra la ex presidente de
actual vicepresidenta cristina fernández
de kirchner y por otro lado también una
resistencia al peronismo que es el
principal partido dentro de la coalición
de gobierno dentro de ese marco general
están los mensajes concretos que los
mencionados contra la reforma del poder
judicial contra el gobierno que muchos
insisten que se está haciendo a través
sobre todo decretos de necesidad y
urgencia y con poca intervención del
legislativo aunque el congreso está
funcionando de forma limitada pero está
funcionando y también fue una
manifestación que interpeló la oposición
adjuntos por el cambio el partido del ex
presidente mauricio macri que hoy es la
principal fuerza de oposición que se vio
en un lugar un poco difícil porque por
un lado algunos de sus miembros se
sumaron a las manifestaciones
participaron activamente pero otros como
por ejemplo el jefe de gobierno de la
ciudad de buenos aires
horacio rodríguez larreta decidieron no
marchar y consideraron que se ponía en
riesgo a la ciudadanía en una marcha
masiva de estas características en el
medio de la pandemia período muy
brevemente nos quedan cerca de 30
segundos repercusiones en el arco
político se manifestaron desde el
oficialismo
desde el oficialismo le quitaron un poco
de importancia a la marcha dijeron que
fue intensa pero que no hubo tanta
participación y también dijeron que
desde la oposición se fueron yo esta
marcha a pesar de que desde la oposición
insistieron que se trató de una
convocatoria ciudadana a través de redes
sociales